okay grab the power back so carry on
with the story
so
I had UK certificates I'd like
certificates and
cytosensi knew that I was running an
organization with him as the head of the
organization who I was following
he agreed to make I didn't ask him for
this he who again it was volunteered it
and because I'd followed him around the
world twice a year every year
by 1992 it was what 10 years had been
following am I
and
he made me his official representative
for the whole of the UK
and said if anybody else wants to join
him you know why Mario and they were in
the UK they were he would Point them to
me and I would be the if you like the
decision maker of what we could all do
together or not
over the years many many students have
made into black belts and they've left
me for some reason or another
and even though it hurts this is all
part of
you know part of like I started off with
the picture that I didn't like and this
one behind me I I like more
and um
you have to get over it
I I again in the conversation our
cytosensei many many years ago about
this
and he told me about two different for
instances
one was Scentsy I don't know why but
sometimes I just feel like giving up
like you know
and uh
the bubble bursts I've got no interest
whatsoever I wonder why I'm doing it I
wonder why I've spent all this money
traveling and
um
I just don't know what to do
he said yes he's had the same thing even
while he was with her Scentsy training
so I said well what did you do
and he said I just kept training
he said that's my advice to you just
keep trying
now
in the next film I'll be talking about
this so I shall
be bringing up about
how easy it is
to go through this
period of training
when you don't want to train anymore you
you find no enjoyment whatsoever
in the training
so going back to I had akikai third Dan
and by this time uh they were being sent
direct to me rather than we have to go
to see canetska sensei
but
I did after my first Dan I started
making a connection with with knexica
Sensei he came and taught in Cambridge
and the odd thing was he'd been taught
by Chiba Scentsy
and when I grabbed when his um people
his own people grabbed him when he would
demonstrate
they would be flying around everywhere
he could you know use them like a a
puppet of
flexibility and ease and throw them down
but now and then he would call me up
I would grab him or attack him
his Aikido can reverted back
to what he was told by cheaper Sensi it
become very sharp he'd become very
focused
and he could perform the techniques on
me
in the lunch break I remember it well in
the lunch break outside the dojo that
we'd moved dojos from the first Judo
play side to
taught and we went to another place
where we had permanent mats in Cambridge
outside there was a there was a mound of
grass
and we would have sandwiches there so I
bought food for him as well as everybody
else and um we were there and he could
speak English
so no need for Japanese translation
and I said to him
since you changed your Aikido
when I grab you or attack you and it's
different to when your people grabbed me
so he said yes you're right he said but
that's because you've been taught by a
side of Sensei
didn't you know it's an honor isn't it
but why did he say that
we go back into class for the afternoon
period And he says to his people
and they're all he's well there's my
Cambridge students as well I had up to
19 black belts I was very proud of the
club then plus all the queue grades
so I've been a very big Club
that had built up over the years
and he stopped and said he stands out in
the middle and he says um Tony is the
only person who gives me a hundred
percent
uh attack and he's the only person on
this
to tell me doing Aikido
and I thought
why is he lecturing his own people why
would you develop people from beginner
to black belt and there was a lot of
them because they used to follow him
very devotedly
why would he be scolding and giving this
information to his
own students the ones he developed I
found this very odd anyhow he was
praising me and um
I thought Here We Go Again more people
gonna dislike me
so even today everybody seems to know me
in the UK my name
I've known pretty much throughout the
world I suppose I could have been around
a long time
I've had more people dislike me than
like me
I don't know what I do wrong but I must
be some think you know
I said on one of my earlier
films I think it was the first one about
how
senior black belts and I'm talking about
up to six then
who who are favoring the war in Ukraine
and want Russia to win and annihilate
the ukrainians that's not how sense is
idea
people disliking me just because the
sense is like me
isn't
no sense is Aikido
I'm not asking them to like me
going back I had this really big Club in
Cambridge I then built another dojo
and then I built a third dojo in my
garden I I first had the second dojo in
my
large double car garage
it would only hold 18 people at maximum
no space really
but we trained
since the Hendrix come over and opened
it
I believe that was 1992.
and um
I built this really large one in the
garden
it would hold up to 35 40 people really
lovely Dojo showers bunk beds
and it was it was great
I often wish I'd never left it but I did
I then retired from business
and
oh I'll go back and answer
I I trained for 23 years every single
day Aikido in some form either at class
or on my own at night or on my own in
the mornings or before I go to bed every
day I wouldn't miss it for 23 years
after 23 years I took a partner on in my
business
I told him I wanted to knock down the
Bungalow that cytosensi stayed in and
built a house
so we agreed that I would go and do that
and I got immersed in that and then
after 23 years I only went three times a
week to class
and and that was the break from
all those years to
three times a week was still a lot for
most of you are listening to this
and that's where we'll get to about
commitment
the
ending up with connects cassettsy that I
would meet him in London and we would go
to eat lunch on Sundays at um I can't
remember the place now but there's you
go sort of under this shopping center
and there's all these oriental food
places where you would eat and I
wouldn't meet him with his wife and
their new baby
and we would have conversation and we
we got on well
and um
and I also really liked uh
tomorrow Scentsy
hi I'm dick I'm digressing
so I had the organization cytosensei
said I was the head of his organization
well I had to explain to him that we had
an all UK organization where we gave out
UK certification and he said I I'm not
worried about that the only reason I
wanted to have aikai was
um to save you an embarrassment with
conetska in the UK and so it was a
opening of a door for you
by the time we got I got my fourth down
the Saito Sensei decided that um he was
going to
no issue I could go anymore only to
those who asked him for it but he would
issue
certification that would be
written up and made by himself
and um
from then on
you had the choice of two aikikai his
and I had plenty of my own UK ones in
the UK what you do is some of your
seniors they they watch other people
let's say they will go and watch several
different teachers who are fifth down
level
they would say Scentsy we're not looking
at through rose-colored glasses that
you're something you're not but we
looked at the fifth dance and we think
that you're equal to them
why are you not fit then I said well if
you put it to a board vote of the
seniors then I'll accept the level
so
I didn't realize at the time that this
is a system
also by the
Japanese as well as the system in the UK
it's just that it hadn't got this IQ
kite this little office at the top of in
humbu
where where ikikai was created a Sensei
created the ikikai but because he wanted
everybody of all the different styles of
Aikido under one umbrella one roof so
they could all say yes even though
you're doing all these different styles
let's have one thing in common that is
let's all be saying that we're doing
Aikido and we'll call us or call it the
ikikai as a body
so I got my fourth down I got my fifth
down from him and he said to me do you
want I can Kai or my
I said censor you're my teacher I don't
why would I want ikikai I don't follow
their Style
I don't follow the teachers I go on
their seminars but there you are my
master you are the one I follow it would
be a great honor for me to hold you off
certification
over the years I had I I've got all his
um
weapon Scrolls I'm supposed to be I know
whether I call it a master in weapons
but um a few of us have that in the
world today we don't seem to boast about
it but we've all got them
and cytosensis stayed up all night after
he awarded you with them and with his
calligraphy set he would write all the
information there's so much information
it stretches for meters each scroll and
it tells you it's almost like there's
Secrets inside there it's not just
saying oh he done the same cancer
Brewery okay and
um the partner practice
it goes into in depth about detail
and to be honest
unless you're Japanese I don't
understand it but I'm told by Japanese
person that only if you're Japanese can
you understand the depths because she's
passing on information
so they would be classed in the old days
of Secrets From The Master to his best
disciples
so I hold them and
um
when I got my fist down that was in
1994.
and then just before
his death he had throat cancer he didn't
tell us that it was terminal he said oh
they fixed it they had been Hospital
they're fixed I'll be okay where in fact
he wasn't okay but he didn't tell us
so when we finally did find out a few
years later not that many years but a
few years later that he was dying of
cancer
I had a phone call from a European top
teacher who was also fit down
and very well liked by cytos NC
it caused me up and says correctly Tony
let's go to Walmart and
um before since he dies let's get off
sixth down off in
and I'd read somewhere that they'd done
this without Scentsy
and how people scorned these people for
doing such a thing
so were they really the grades they were
or was I sent you just thanking them for
coming to see him off
I didn't want to do this so this person
went off got his sixth down I wouldn't
do it
I waited until since it passed and then
I went to his wake in ilama it was a
wonderful affair
but that's another story
I then linked up because you know we
need to keep friends we need to keep
connections and Scentsy Hendricks was
kind enough to to help out and be our
teacher because she's a full-time Aikido
teacher one's Ryan Dojo still today
and she said to me Tony you should be
six then I'll get you six down
so she contacts the hombre dojo and the
hombre Dojo who again is the Archie guy
and they said Yes We Really respect side
of Sensei
um
he was Diet down then like ikai
we really respect him
and we will gladly give you your sixth
down
but there's one snag and that is
um you don't have a lake fourth and
fifth
so
as long as you're happy to pay for the
fourth down fifth down and sixth down we
will
right the certificates
I had to sell at that time I had to sell
a very precious it was a very big
Buddhist Bell there was a bell I don't
know
perhaps
870 centimeters 60 70 it was massive
massive Bell on the stand that just been
refurbished by one of my students he
gave it to me as a present
it was wonderful but I had to sell that
to get enough funds to pay for the
certificate plus the organization
helped me out and played for them
at the time I was very gullible and
thought that um
all this money
around about 2 000 pounds
just going off and I got my six down
I then decided to I I've moved
businesses three times
I had a massive business multi millions
of pounds turnover I made the flagship
dealership the first one in Europe
and it was very stressful
the doctor recommended that I eat with
all my kid I recommended that I retired
if I'm not my next stop would be a
coughing
this was the age of around about 50.
so
somebody approached me to sell the
business and I sold it
and I decided that I'd always wanted to
visit it on many occasions a a Greek
island of kefalonia
so I decided to sell the business
sell my house with the dojo
and move to
kefalonia where I've built a house and a
dojo inside the house
the dojo I'm gonna guess to hold about
25 six people
wasn't as big as the one I had
that I was leaving
so we moved there
and you know
cytosensei as I've said it he was more
than just a master of Aikido he was like
a fatherly figure and you could talk to
him about anything
I could I was just part of the
conversation after being with him for so
many years
and what I didn't realize was there was
a lot of the black belt side helped
create and get them to their levels they
didn't like me leaving it was as if
I was letting them down
so a lot of them the majority actually
left and went and followed other Masters
what I still can't understand to this
day is they say it was because I was
leaving and going aboard
so I was going to Greece
some went and left and
joined Pat and picks fancy
who's in America
some went and followed Daniel tutan who
was in France
uh it was very unusual that I was losing
all these people because they said I was
letting them down and leaving
as if I was their father
and yet
I was only going to Greece
one student who sadly passed away now
one student
said quite loudly
well if I want you you will be my stay
my Samson if I want you I'll come see
you in Greece
it just didn't seem a problem to him
and yeah it was a problem to others and
yet they chose senses in different
countries
perhaps if I had never left I'd still be
there today but is that having
is that them being false were they ever
really
a truth
ful Susan or were they just there for me
the next film that I should be making I
should be coming
to summary of what all these films have
been about
I just wanted you to know about my
commitment to the art of Aikido
and it has been yes for me but the day
my teacher gave me my brown bout and the
club to run
you can have a choice you can become a
teacher who demonstrates to the class
and likes their Aura and their ego and
everything that goes with it pat it on
the back perhaps on the back and admired
how good they are or you can become a
teacher and you can start looking at
your students
and trying to First help them
and then start to befriend them and then
start to be a person they can share
their personal Thoughts with the ones
off the mat as well as on the mat
and you have to make a choice as a
teacher whether you want to be that
person or whether you want to stay a
Sensei and not let them near you and not
let them penetrate you
just be there to teach the Arts and not
to be
a guidance a fatherly figure a friend
and all these things and when that
first queue was handed over to me in the
club I was so astounded
that I decided
that I couldn't think for Tony anymore I
had to think as a teacher for others
those who were going to follow me for
the future Years thank you for listening